what right now because I feel like you
have great taste in music and you're
kind of like
you know you're not like uh you might
you might have some old head taste in
you for being a young kid but what are
you listening to I want to say I got old
head taste I just think I like to go
back yeah but um
okay
the point may be proven I've been
listening to a lot of Al Green lately
but I've been listening to a lot of
older music for samples you know just to
listen oh it had taste for sure yeah the
silvers you know what I'm saying just
but for sample purposes and because it's
[__] good like of course wine is
always going to be fine wine you can
always go back and watch Michael Jordan
highlights and they're still oh they're
crazy Pete Maravich no something not so
much you know what I'm saying yeah once
you get to like when the TVs were black
and white on YouTube the highlights
become really bad yeah because you're
like oh these guys would be terrible
today they couldn't last because they
were just playing against a bunch of
guys like look like me yeah and I was
like [__] is plumbing and then okay
yeah I got a game tonight right at the
National Basketball Association but um
any hip-hop you're liking that is like
uh you know anything new like Have you
listened to new little yachty album no I
haven't yet I haven't yet crazy it's
it's dope yeah yeah it's a Trippy
psychedelic like yeah not I seen that it
was like an experimental album um shout
out to him for like it takes a lot of
nuts to do some [__] like that the type
of music you would love to listen to if
you're a shroom and hard yeah some good
shrooming music nah for sure yeah and I
gotta check it out I'll definitely check
it out what is your go-to shruman music
um
um let me see
to go to just anything Soulful anything
Soulful
um and it's also you can just type in
shroom playlist
yeah back to Marco Nirvana [__]
um yeah yeah well entertainment what
song is that um Entertainer it's a big
ass song and I'm crazy for not knowing
the time listen to Nirvana on troops yes
shout out to you yeah it's a CR it's
crazy
um Mac Miller is great on shrooms yeah
Travis isn't uh Tame Impala yeah Tame
Impala of course that ASAP LSD LSD I
feel like a head ass naming all these
like big shroom songs but that's what I
do I just go on yeah
and just hit play you good yeah you're
super good worst trip you've ever had
oh I've had a penny I've got a bad one
I've had just one bad one bro I was it
was it was just a dumb reason why I did
I was in a hall in the crib alone I just
shouldn't have did it I was in a dark
place in my life honestly Truman at home
alone bro it was crazy it was horrible
pandemic no not pain so what happened
were you just like overthinking
everything freaking out yeah I was yeah
I was like really on panic mode like in
life like I was on like full-on panic
mode like it was crazy bro it was it was
not something I like the revisit it was
just it was a bad trip